من القدس الاسيره المحرره شروق دويات شروق
اهلا بك تسمعينني
[تصفيق]
بسمعك ارجو ان لك الميكروفون ارجو ان تصفي
لنا هذه اللحظات
شروق
يعني هي لحظات صراحه
يعني يعني فرحه يعني كثير كبيره بس هي
برضه ممزوجه بالالم صراحه انا ل هلقيت حاس
حالي بحلم مش حاس حالي انه انا بساحه
دارنا مش حاس حالي انه انا شفت امي ابوي
خواتي اخوتي يعني كل الاقارب كل الجيران
فله القيت انا عن جد حاسه حالي بحلم كثير
كبير بس برضه هي يعني اول شيء طبعا الحمد
لله انه ربنا من علي بهذا الفرج ثاني شيء
عن جد بترحم على شهداء غزه وبتمنى انه ان
شاء الله انه الحرب تتوقف عليهم باسرع وقت
ممكن وزي ما حكيت لك انه هي فرحه كثير
كبيره بس برضو هي فرحه ممزوجه بالالم هو
عرس وطني صراحه مؤجل لحين انتصار غزه ان
شاء الله هل لك ان تصفي لنا الايام التي
سبقت ابلاغك او كيف تم ابلاغك بانك من
المعنيات
بالافراج ما سمعت السؤال
منيح سالتك شروق كيف تم ابلاغ م ت السؤال
لاني ما سمعته منيح كيف تم ابلاغكم بانك
معنيه بالافراج اه
طبعا تم ابلاغنا يعني اه اوك هلكت بالدفعه
الاولى لما دخلوا علينا القوه دخلوا كانه
هم فايتين قوه قمع فما حسينا انه في افراج
فبعدين صاروا بسرعه يحكوا مثلا اسم
الاسيره ويحكوا لها يلا بتتكل بش
وبتطلع وك يعني كانه يعني هم يعني كثير
كثير كان شيء غريب بس اليوم مارسوا معنا
الضغط النفسي اكث اث خلونا ننتظر لساعات
اكبر يعني تقريبا احنا وصلنا المسكوبيه
على الساعه 3 خلونا فيها للساعه 12 بالليل
كل شوي يحكوا لنا راح تروحوا بس كمان شوي
وكمان شوي وكمان اكم من دقيقه صارت اكم من
ساعات بس الحمد لله بالنهايه انه انا صرت
بين اهلي وبين احبابي وبين عائلتي الحمد
لله يعني وبيتنا شروق كم كانتك الطريقه
اللي كان يعني يخبرونا فيها
هي 16 عام قضيت منها النص وبس 10 دخلت
بالسنه
التاسعه كيف كان احساسك عندما بلغتي بانك
ستخرجين كان صراحه انا لحديت ما حقول لي
اني رح اروح ما كنت مصدقه ما صدقت غير
لهلق لما وصلوني على البلد وقرات على
الكارما انه دخلت صور باهر وما صدقت غير
لما كمان حضنت اهلي وانه انا بينهم فكان
الشعور كثير غريب ومش قادر حتى حتى اوصفه
مش قادره اعبر عنه لانه اول مره بحس بهيك
شعور بس هو شعور كثير حلو وصراحه ما بحس
بالحريه الا اللي فقدها بس برضه بحكي لك
انه في في الم وفي غصه
بالقلب كيف كانت ظروف اعتقالهم خاصه في
السنوات الاخيره او الشهور
الاخيره يعني هو طبعا السجن صعب بس دائما
احنا يعني بحاول انه نعلم مع ويات بعض
نصبر بعض بس هي الاونه الاخيره صراحه بحكي
لك انه بالمره يعني ما عمري شفت مرحله
لهالدرجه انها صعبه كانت في حمله شرسه
كثير كبيره على الاسرى والاسيرات مارسوا
معنا كثير شغلات اولا سياسه القمع ثانيا
سياسه التجويع والتعطيش كمان الاقتضاء جوا
الغرف يعني الغرفه كانت تسع اربع اسيرات
صاروا يحطوا فيها ثمانيه وتس اسيرات ما
كانوا يجيبوا اكل على العدد كانوا سحبوا
كل الانجازات اللي نن حاربنا عشان ناخذ هي
الانجازات فبح كي لك كان الوضع جدا جدا
صعب وهلق انا تقريبا تاركه وراي 51 اسيره
وبرضه وضعهم كثير صعب تركتم مع نفس الشيء
ما كنا نطلع على الساحه ل 47 يوم بالمره
ما كنا نطلع على الساحه بس كنا نطلع على
الحمام 10 دقائق نتحمم ونرجع على الغرف
وبسرعه بسرعه وطبعا غير عن المعامله اللي
كانوا عاملونا اياها سبات راخ ما كان
يهمهم ما كان يفرق معهم وب
1910 طبعا نحن خلال هي الايام ق تعرضنا
القعه الاولى كانت ب 10 القم الثانيه كانت
ب 19 10 رشنا غاز تعاملوا معنا كان رجال
ما عملوا خصوصيه لانه احنا نساء فكان
الوضع صعب بس برضه احنا كنا نقوي بعض
ودائما كانت معنوياتنا عاليه ولا شي طبعا
را راح يكسرنا هل هناك شروط ابلغكم بها او
اشياء قالوا لكم بان ممنوع ان تقوموا بها
عند ابلاغكم بالافراج
عنكم اه طبعا حطوا علينا شروط زي انه
ممنوع مثلا انه نعمل اي مظاهر راح ممنوع
انه نشارك ولا باي نشاطات فهو هي حطوا
علينا هي الشروط و وبس يعني وهي الشروط
طبعا على الكل حطوها واي مثلا اي حدا مثلا
رح يخترق هي الشروط رح يتم اعاده اعتقاله
فصراحة ربطت فيها كيف صبرت انت في سنوات
الاعتقال ووجهت كلمه ل اهل غزه وكذلك
للمعتقلين في السجون الاسرائيليه خلينا
نحكي عن الاداءات الاول اللي صار في بيت
اسرائ نعم لانه صراحه انا بحكي لك انا في
غصه كثير كبير في قلبي هقيت انه انا تارك
وراي اسيرات حتى لو انهم انه ان شاء الله
هم ما رح يطولوا لانه عن جد هم بيعتقل على
لا شيء يعني هم قاعدين بيعتقل على بس
بوستات او شيء لا يذكر صراحه ما في في
حريه التعبير عن الراي ف فاي حدا صاروا
يجيبوه اياه على السجن واغلبهم من اراضينا
في الداخل المحتل وكمان في غصه كثير كبيره
انه مش كل الاسرى يعني تحرروا بس انا
متاكده انه ان شاء الله زي ما ربنا من علي
بالفرج انه هم كمان رح ربنا يمن عليهم
بالفرج وبتمنى انه هذا الحكي يكون باقرب
وقت وباق فرصه ممكنه لانه بحكي لك انا
لهلق تارك قطعه مني جوا سجن الدامون لانه
برضه في نساء ك يعني كبار بالسن فوحده
عمرها 70 سنه هي شو ق طرفت ذنب عشان
يجيبوها على السجن وبرضه في امهات جوا
السجن طيب وبرضه في اقتضا كثير كثير جوا
السجن عشان هيك انا عارف الوضع لما طلعت
من السجن عشان هيك في تخوف في تخوف كثير
كبير على الاسيرات عندما تم القاء القبض
عليك بالنسبه لاه غزه يعني عن جد بحكي لهم
اصبروا اصبروا اصبروا ان شاء الله وما
صبروا الا نصر ساعه عندما تم القاء القبض
عليك شروق وان كنت طالبه في الجامعه حكم
عليك ب 16 عاما سجنا ومضيت منها سبع سنوات
شروق الان كيف تنظرين للمستقبل بعدما ضاعت
كل هذه السنوات وانقطع مشوارك
الدراسي صوت
الكاميرا يعني بدايه انا مضيت ثمان سنوات
داخل الاسر ودخلت بالسنه التاسعه بس هذا
الشيء ما را يكسرني وراح اكمل مشواري
التعليمي وطبعا ه الشيء بالعكس خلق تحدي
كثير كبير عندي وهي مش النهايه بالعكس هي
بدايه ل لحياه جديده
لشروق كم كان عمرك عندما تم القاء القبض
عليك شروق رح اكمل مشوار التعليمي كم كان
عمرك 18 شهرين 18 شهرين طيب اكيد كان معك
في السجن من كانوا اقل عمرا كانوا في عمر
الطفوله طبعا بال 2015 يعني هي زادت
الاعتقالات كثير بال 2015 2016 وكان في
طبعا بنات تحت السن 18 اللي هم 15 و1 سنه
وكبروا طبعا بالسجن وحققوا انجازات كثير
كبيره بالسجن وهذا الشيء حتى لو احنا ان
سجنا صغار بالعمر كبرنا جوا السجن وحققنا
كثير انجازات بالنسبه نا وحتى لو كنا جوا
السجن هذا الشي ما راح يهز من عزيمتنا
بالمره بالعكس هذا الشي اعطانا تحدي وقوه
وامل كثير
اكبر نكمل
مشوارنا معكم بالجن شرو وانت تعرفتي عليها
من كانت وكم كان عمرها
اصغر اسيره كان عمرها 12 سنه كان عمرها 12
سنه طبعا هي قعدت ست اشهر داخل الاسر بس
يعني لما كنت اطلع عليها هي يعني طفله
طفله بس كنت اشوفها ما كنت اشوفها انه هي
لازم يكون محلها جوا السجن كنت اشوفها
صراحه طفله بتلعب بالحاره مع بنات الحاره
بس هيك كنت اشوفها فكان الشيء عن جد صعب
انك تشوف اسيره اللي هي عمرها تكون مكبله
عمرها 12 سنه بتتعامل معامله الكبار وعادي
كانه مش لكن حتى في خصوصيه
للعمر يعني لا يتم التفريق في التعامل وفي
الاجراءات بين طفل
وبين سنه احنا دائما كنا يعني نبث في بعض
الامل شروق نعم لم يكون هناك تفريق في
المعامله وفي ظروف السجن بين الاطفال وبين
الراشدين طبعا هم ما بيعملوا خصوصيه لا
للعمر مثلا ه لما يكون مثلا في قاصرات
تعاملوا معهم كانهم عادي كراشد ما في
خصوصيه حتى احنا اننا كنساء ما في خصوصيه
بيتعاملوا معنا
كرجال كل شي طبعا هم بيشوفونا بالنهايه ما
بيشوفونا كنساء هم بيشوفونا انه احنا بين
قوصين يعني بد مارسوا علينا كل كل انواع
يعني الممارسات
الصعبه فما في
خصوصيه شكرا لك من القدس الاسيره المحرره
شروق
دويات